[Music]
all right Mother's Day just a few days
away we've been talking about it all
morning but we've got a great event to
celebrate with art food and charity this
is a collaboration of some incredible
people and Minds all coming together on
Friday for a big event so we start here
with Anna Gomez you are the owner of via
Brazil steakhouse and you're going to be
hosting this event and the proceeds are
going to go to Miracle flights that's
right Linda joining us and Alexander
thank you for being here the incredible
artist behind all of the art that's
going to be for sale with the proceeds
so Anna let's talk about the event it's
on Friday this is just a snippet of some
of the things that you can enjoy and
divulge in thank you thank you so much
so yes we are going to be doing pasta
appetizers complimentary at the
beautiful event and we are so excited
because Alexander Franco is going to
bring like over 80 pieces of the art
wonderful so everybody can come and buy
and we're going to serve you the full
delicious food and wine complimentary on
us okay so we just want you to come and
support the miracle flights because
Porsche parts of the Porsche are going
to go to Miracle flights so free event
to to to go to and you're going to have
this incredible food items and options
now if you've never eaten there you are
in luck because this is definitely a
good time to get over there food is
excellent at via Brazil um really quick
run me through some of the yummy things
that you have here okay so we have a
Brazilian salga genius with chicken with
cheese as well as with shrimp the
meatballs Brazilian meatballs are 100
beef we also have a Cubana sandwich oh
cheesecake Caprese salad so everything
is Super Fresh and delicious all the
good stuff so now you go there and
you're going to be also looking at this
beautiful artwork Alexander you have a
relationship with Miracle flights and
now here with via Brazil 80 pieces is a
lot of work what drives you to to do
this charity for this organization well
it's very important to have a large
connection with the community I think
most important so now I try to go
through that because you know it's about
what we give so much well you are very
talented I've seen the website with some
of your some of your big beautiful
pieces or what can folks expect all
different sizes and price points yes
we're going to have a large selection of
work uh we I will say more than a
hundred pieces all together Mosley
original is one of the kind pieces and
the idea is to have something for each
individual so it's kind of seals because
we have the perfect match present for
the mothers yeah yes Mother's Day and I
know of course John was noticing that
that Kurt Cobain that caught his eye
right away very talented now the
proceeds for this incredible event are
going to go to Miracle fights yes Linda
I know we've talked to you before but
really quick for folks at home who
aren't aware of what Miracle flights
does go ahead and share with us we
provide free commercial airline flights
to kids and adults who need to get to
life-changing medical care we could not
do the work that we do without Community
Support like what we're doing on Friday
this allows us to get more people more
flights excellent it's such a wonderful
cause this is what happens collaboration
at its best so again Friday is the event
we'll have this information on our
website Alexander beautiful artwork
Linda always the pleasure Anna always a
pleasure to have you on the show go eat
dine and celebrate our beautiful mothers
I'm going to send it to a quick break
we'll